all right first thanks for staying and
for those that aren't staying thanks for
staying that long it's fine I'm not
offended
I'd ask we've been here a long time can
I just stand up and stretch because I
feel a lot of people here yawning and
getting tired and we all kind of need a
little just don't leave like stretch
enjoy yourself okay that felt good
didn't it that's good all right all
right now so I'm going to talk to you
about it which honestly probably my most
personal talk I've ever given it's seven
comma stakes and go and when to avoid
them
fantastic introduce me or get darker
also written a number of libraries and
tools and go and the reason I highlight
them is because I'm actually in talk
about these aren't common mistakes these
are my common mistakes that I've made in
go and I've seen it other things and
maybe you're making them too all right
so how do you feel when you see that
does anyone else experience a bit of
pain we've been conditioned in this
country and maybe a lot of countries
from one we're very young that failure
is a bad thing and that we shouldn't
fail and it experiences pain and anguish
whenever we see something like this and
it's because it's so deeply ingrained in
who we are the failure is something that
should be avoided at all costs this is a
quote it might as well be from Yoda it's
not but it says do you all know the
difference between a master and a
beginner the Masters failed more times
in the beginners trot and edie Catmull
founder of Pixar said we need to think
about failure differently most people
think mistakes are necessary evil
mistakes aren't a necessary evil they
aren't evil at all
they are inevitable consequence of doing
something new and as such should be seen
as valuable all right
go is a new language relatively speaking
I think a lot of us are trying to do new
things with it
just consequently we're going to make
mistakes I personally make lots of
mistakes and there's a human tendency to
want to cover up our mistakes and not to
broadcast them and I'm completely
fighting that human tendency as I share
my mistakes with YouTube and all of you
in this room and anyone who watches this
video later so do we know who this is
it's also someone else his name's
Michael Michael Bluth from a TV show
Arrested Development and if you watch
this show you you generally relate to
this character because he doesn't want
to make mistakes there's another
character who makes huge mistakes who we
laugh at and don't find is relatable and
hopefully by the you'll see kind of a
contrast here so the first mistake and a
lot of these are related to the first
every one of these mistakes are ghosts
specific they're not general programming
mistakes they're part of the language
most of them have to do with what I
think are the two biggest new features
one is concurrency and the other one is
interfaces which guess some exist in
other languages but the way govern go
does is unique so the first one is not
accepting interfaces now I think it's
important and this is another storm is
pretty go savvy it's one recognize that
in there's state and behavior these are
two fundamental principles of computer
program types can go can express both
state and behavior state is equal to the
data structure and behavior equals the
methods interfaces are one of those most
powerful features they permit
extensibility they're defined by methods
meaning that go interfaces are
behavioral only the adherence is
satisfied only by behavior not at all by
the data structure not at all by the
state so I want to use an example from
hugo if you haven't heard of hugo it's
the fastest static site generator there
is just a little little story about this
we got a bug report I don't know six
months ago
someone's trying to build something with
like 15,000 posts and they said they
tried every static site generator that
there was most
didn't ever finish hours later had never
finished most crashed one finished in an
hour and a half Hugo finished in ten
seconds so it's fast
now most people do also don't have
15,000 posts but if it can do that and
ten seconds it can compile your blog a
lot faster than that and so this is this
is all code examples from code that
mostly ira so first one is don't do this
so what are we trying to do here first
just setting up the stage in this slide
we've defined a new byte buffer and
we're writing to it there's nothing
wrong with that specific part but the
next thing what are we doing we're
grabbing the bytes and we're passing
them into another function and the
signature of that function here that
only accepts a byte slice and what does
that do well it creates a new reader all
right so we've gone from something that
satisfied a reader to extracting the
bytes to to creating another reader from
write and you look at that and it seems
pretty obvious but if you look around go
code you'll see things like this all
it's not just in my code
it's in a lot of other people's code too
so instead right what's the solution is
pretty obvious here all we do is convert
it instead of taking a byte array we're
going to convert it to take an i/o
reader and in doing that it were taking
interface instead of specific data type
and it's a lot more efficient so mistake
number two is piggybacking on that it's
used not using i/o reader and i/o writer
and it's a you know if you look around
different libraries it's amazing how
often this is not being happening so
what our i/o reader and our writer
they're simple and flexible interfaces
for many operations around input and
output they provide access to a huge
wealth of functionality and I really
want to underscore how much you can do
with with these two things and they keep
operations very extensible and they're
really simple I mean you can't define
simpler interfaces than these and
you know light of time you can read it
but the reader has a read method that's
the behavior it expects and the writer
has a write method that's the behavior
it expects so here's an example from
Cobra CLI commander which powers
kubernetes and Hugo and so this this
line is actually one of the most
powerful lines in the entire program
what this does is it lets you for each
command like a command is like git clone
and clone would be the command it lets
you define a specific output for that
because we've enabled it to be IO writer
it accepts a whole slew of different
outputs logging systems Network layers
there's a whole lot of different things
you can do in this case would default to
OS standard standard error which it
again adheres to that same interface
VIPRE is another tool it's another it's
kind of a companion to Cobra unless you
do configuration management so it
automatically reads JSON and Tamil and
the mo files and environment variables
and remote key value stores and you know
this is right from that go there's
actually from a pull request I didn't
write this one but it was a great
learning experience so someone
contributed this read buffer config and
they passed in buff bytes buffer right
there's nothing wrong with this code
this code runs fine it works really well
but it's very prescriptive about what's
going to happen right much better is to
define it as an IO reader which by its
buffer adheres to it adheres to that
interface when we do this enables our
code to be much more extensible now now
people can pass a whole lot of different
things into this
whereas before we're very prescriptive
by the way for me if you have a question
just shout it out well not a raise your
hand or something but like I don't want
to wait till the end and then you forgot
it so so I'm assuming no ones have
questions it you know I think a lot of
this I think it's obvious when you look
at the slides hopefully you also think
it's obvious when you're writing the
code maybe it's not as obvious so so
third one is sorry requiring broad
interfaces so interfaces are composable
should only accept interfaces that
require the methods that they need
functions should not accept a broad
interface when a narrow one would work
you can compose broad interfaces made up
from narrower ones so you use a couple
examples this is a Faro
fs it's a library that I wrote
specifically to make it so I could do
testing better because with Hugo we do
lots of creating sites and then
destroying throughout the test I don't
want to write to the file system but I
don't want to rewrite my code so luckily
because the OS standard in different OS
package defines all these interfaces
really well I was able to write a really
thin library that lets you do neat
things specifically it gives you
cross-platform memory back filesystem
that's completely interchangeable with
the OS package and so what do we do
inside this we have I've defined a file
interface and has a whole lot of
different interfaces that it's composed
of and it's tempting when you're
defining a function throughout there RL
is to say hey I'm going to include that
broad interface I'm gonna include file
everywhere right and if you've used
other languages a lot about language
it's kind of actually a pattern you look
for in go we don't want to do this why
don't we want to do this why don't we
say well what if I don't want to
implement the entire file because I have
good reasons not to write but now I
can't use this anymore so much better
we're only using the read function so
you should only use the reader interface
we shouldn't use that broad interface
all right mistake for methods versus
functions I know this one trips up a lot
of a lot of people and it did me a lot
when I first started so how if you look
come from an object orange background
really what are the rest of you come
from like I know Robert doesn't but I
don't some of you just don't raise your
hands I guess right and we've learned
that we've been ingrained with that a
lot of us that was the first program
environment that we really learned and
so we've been engrained in how to use it
and part of that is owes a lot really
method heavy and there's a natural draw
for object
our programmers to define everything via
structs and methods but what is the
function so let's kind of define it a
function is operations performed on n
number of inputs result on n number of
outputs the same inputs will always
result in the same outputs so functions
don't depend on state that's how they
can adhere to that what is a method
method defines the behavior of a type
this is very specific alright so
remember it goes back to the whole
interface being behaviors it defines the
behavior of a type a function that it's
a function that operates against the
specific value and it should use state
the whole point of is is to use state it
needs to be logically connected with
that state and functions can be used
with with interfaces so method by
definition or bound to a specific type
of functions can accept interfaces as
input so example from hugo and this is
an example of one that I think is really
you know pages a major data structure
within Hugo because it creates website
so it creates lots of pages and there's
tons of methods on it and there's a big
draw to put everything down is a method
and initially when I wrote this function
short codes are kind of like template
macros and there's a there's a draw to
make this a method as well and when I
started was a method I looked at you
know why is this a method it's not
actually doing anything with that it's
using it but it's using it as input the
same input the same page every time will
always result in the same output it's
not manipulating that page and does that
make sense am i explaining that
reasonably well a lot of people are
nodding wow that means you're even
listening and paying attention this is
going pretty well for none at all right
so if you look here we're really not
manipulating it at all we're just using
it as if it was input
shouldn't you be thinking about what's
exported enough yes you're right you're
totally right your point is valid that's
it that's a very valid point so to
repeat the question is why would you not
consider it something about the state
with the page
it certainly is part of that right and
you could make an argument to do this to
make it a method in fact is it's not
changing that state at all right it's
using a state it's also using the string
as input so it's using multiple things
as input here the fact is it by
definition of the function because the
inputs and outputs given the same inputs
in the same outputs it's always the same
methods don't do that methods take
inputs they've changed often will change
the state and result in an outfit maybe
it's the same output but that state
change is going to be the difference now
you can include it right there's not a
hard set rule not to include it and
sometimes logically make sense to group
things together around something and
often you know and going nice thing is
you can actually have an empty struct or
even nil and you can create methods on
those things right but typically those
are for logical groupings rather than
treating them as methods so really
they're acting more as functions of that
result so mistake 5 is pointers risk
values so I've heard a lot of people
when I was learning ago I heard a lot of
people say always use pointers there's
so much faster or always used values
because maybe that's where they came
from right if they came from I think
it's like Java they want to always use
values because they want to copy
everything it's not generally question
of performance but it's one of shared
access if you want to share the value
with a function or method then use a
point if you don't want to share it then
use a value right so generally
performance isn't the thing you should
worry about it should be about access
and what how you want to use it so
pointers versus value receivers is
another question I get all a lot I see a
lot of people people don't know what to
do a lot of the default answers always
use the top one
that's what generally people say because
it's usually right
but again pointer receivers are good
when you want to share values and often
with methods you do and because methods
are manipulating things so that's a very
common thing remember these are not safe
freaking current access right because
they're also using shared then you got
value receivers if you want the value
copied then you use these values if the
type is an empty struck right so there's
no value to it again you should use
values and these are safe for concurrent
access so another example from a pharaoh
in this case right we're calling closed
on a file right why would we want that
shared right where were you sending a
pointer why it seemed because we
modified state that's exactly what and
we want that universally modified
another example this is from the time
package right in the time package it
does use it uses methods but it uses
them on values not on point why would it
want to do that anyone because time is
ticking yeah that's really this one
should be obvious what thank you for
being the brave person to shadow an
answer okay
yeah yeah time was ticking all right so
mistake six thinking of errors is
strength so when I started learning ago
all I heard about was all these
complaints about errors and how go
handled errors I think with all these
conversations people completely missed
the point of what go errors are and how
powerful they can be yes you don't throw
but you know you can do a lot of things
with them so first a lot of people when
they learn go are surprised to find it
error is not a tuck what is there it's
an interface it's a very simple
interface it's an interface that has
only one behavior to find on it it has
an error method that returns
string all right so you can do a lot
with that
so first the standard errors are often
sufficient right so you can call
Perrineau and provide a string and it
will create a value of type error of
interface that adheres the interface
there you can also export error
variables that can easily check so from
Hugo this was some coding Hugo we
created error new and we gave you know
pretty standard error there all right
this is fine it works but how do you
compare that usually people result in
string comparison and that's generally
not the best way to do things so better
is to export it with the variable and
now we can check values right checking
values there's a lot better than
checking strings
I see this in code all over the place
there people are always checking strings
or sub strings to do it this is another
example of actually just the check so
it's the second part outside now you can
create your own custom error types and
these can there's three different
reasons to do this one is you can
provide context to guarantee consistent
feedback all right I see a lot of people
creating errors they have lots of
complex formatting in them don't do that
I'll show a better example you can
provide a type which can be different
from the error value right so the error
doesn't there value and its own type can
be two different things and it's
important and you can do lots of
powerful things with that last is you
can provide dynamic values based on
internal error State so this is an
example from docker does everyone know
docker is raise your hand if you don't
know dr. well I got John that one did
that you're excited
it's good alright so this is from docker
and this is a pull request we got
recently so docker is a complex program
and we're trying to expand our errors
and get better errors and we're trying
to prepare for internationalization in
the future at least somewhere to set the
pull request is and so what we've done
here is they've created this custom air
type which has error code and a message
write the message if you look at error
right what is this is this is how it
adheres to the function what is it doing
it's it's going to has the both the
error code and the string representation
of the message the nice thing is you can
check just code you don't have to look
at the string message when you're using
this that allows you to
internationalization or various
translations that the the message value
can be different from the code itself
from the ghost standard library some
really good examples so this is one
these are just standard errors at the
top to line and cite them because it's
important for the next side in this case
this from the OS package there's path
error that's a very explicit type and if
you look at the signature here or the
definition of it what does it have it
has operation it's got a path has got an
error and then look at how it creates it
it does the formatting for you in the
error function alright so when you
create this error you're going to create
a giving it three explicit things and
it's going to automatically format it
for T now this is a function from inside
the OS packages to the right at one and
it returns an error right and remember
errors in interface so the first thing
it does is returns a standard error
right if F is now return a standard
error invalid which is Saturday but if
it's longer than that it actually and in
certain conditions happen you're going
to want to return a path there right
path there's this explicit error type
that we've defined earlier what we're
doing here is we're we're giving it the
three parameters that we need to we're
not worrying about string formatting
beyond that you can do some pretty
powerful things so in this case this is
a fake function that doesn't exist but
what
we're conceiving up here is you might be
writing something and say you know what
if there's a path there I actually don't
care I want to continue I want to do
something right I don't care what the
path there is there might be four
different type values for path there I
don't care which one is I just want to
see any path there I'm going to handle
it one way otherwise I'm going to fail
and I'm going to you know call of fatal
another example here is this is a
similar thing we're checking the type if
if the types of certain thing we're
going to be fine with it in this case
we're actually checking for the specific
value there too right so you can do a
lot of things by checking with the types
to remember the type can be independent
of the error value itself and that gives
you a lot of power with errors so there
are a lot more than just strings
all right mistake seven is to be safe or
not to be first you can't make everyone
happy you aren't a jar of Nutella all
right so consider concurrency if you
provide a library someone will use it
concurrently here is going to happen all
right data structures and go or
generally not safe for concurrent access
and values aren't safe you need to
create safe behavior around them all
right so how do you make things safe we
just went through a lot of that with
Aaron's talk so I won't dwell on that so
with the Pharoah we were trying to model
map exactly the the file system in OS so
this is how it looked at initially when
I coded it and it worked really well
until somebody put it in a go routine
and when they ran a bunch of things
concurrently it blew up why to blow up
because it was trying to access the same
thing at the same time so what's a
solution it's a simple solution it's to
use mutexes and add some locks around
right and for this all right that's
pretty clear there now why do you want
to keep things unsafe right when I so
this I gave a presentation earlier and
this this section I got a ton of
feedback on it was mostly constructive I
hadn't made a mistake so this is me
trying to
on that reality is there's lots of
reasons to keep things unsafe safety
comes at it cost it also imposes
behaviors on a consumer right so if we
look you know if we have to find a
proper API it allows the consumers to
add safety as they need and it lets
consumers choose how they want to do it
they can use channels or they can use
mutexes whatever fits their situation so
this is back to the same slide why do we
do it this way
why do we put our lock in here because
that's what the OS package does work
concurrently because it delays things to
the operating system which lets things
run concurrently so we wanted to model
that behavior right so we didn't let it
define above it because in this case it
made a lot of sense to implement here
because it's consistent with the OS
package however maps which are part of
the go are unsafe by design all right
often safety as unnecessary believe
that's the argument for why they're
still that way it enables consumers to
implement safety as needed right so I
just showed an example we're using a map
how do we implement it we use the lock
surrounded with new Texas and the
consumer of that can choose how they
want to implement the safety I also
don't have which I'm not going to go
through because of time and because we
just have a bunch of stuff on channels
but you could also use channels to this
alright so the biggest mistake is is not
making mistakes alright so again from
Edie Catmull failure is a manifestation
of learning and exploring if you aren't
experiencing failure then you are making
a far worse mistake you are being driven
by the desire to avoid and takes me back
to now who do I want to be more like I
want to be more like job a little less
like Michael who makes a huge mistake
and that's my time thank you
so again we have time for like one two
lessons yeah yeah when we go back to a
club okay so one was the overly broad
interfaces or concrete types instead in
fixes
Seavers
you see that you know certainly go vet
and other tools like that could help
with a lot of these things in fact I
think covet does help with some of these
things reality is the reason I think a
lot of these that I want to highlight
them is a they're not obvious I don't
think they're always obvious me a lot of
them it's not obvious when to do it
right sometimes there's a good reason to
do one and sometimes a good reason to do
it the other way and there's a lot of
context involved with that that the code
tooling couldn't help wit because it's
not going to know enough about the
context of how you're using it kind of
the architecture you have behind it and
again these are things that I saw myself
do wrong and it you know I use a lot of
libraries out there and I see it you
know it's being confused in a lot of
places I think the reasons confused it
is it can be confusing because there's
not always a clear answer so I think yes
it can help with some things on the
other side I think education and
experience of using the tools more you
know I think how much I've learned in
the couple years I've been writing going
and as I look through the standard
libraries which I use as inspiration I
think I see differences over the ones
that are created later right I think
even the go team is still learning a
little bit about how this language works
and how best to utilize it and at least
Andrews nodding his head so it's those
wrong and so it's Rob so I think you
know this is their creation but you know
just because your creation doesn't mean
you you know everything about it I think
all of us are starting to explore kind
of different ways to do things in in it
and a nice thing with the language
that's so flexible in the way that it is
it lets you express yourself in
different ways you know we're all still
learning so all right
okay so if there's no more questions and
just watch you all the speakers